some of the best opportunities to learn
are the moments in which we are
perplexed those moments in which you
begin to wonder in question these
moments have happened throughout history
and have led to some truly amazing
discoveries take this story for example
there once was a fellow named Archimedes
he was born in 287 BC in the city of
Syracuse and Sicily he was a Greek
mathematician physicist engineer
inventor and astronomer one day
Archimedes was summoned by the King of
Sicily to investigate if he had been
cheated by a goldsmith the King said he
had given a goldsmith the exact amount
of gold needed to make a crown however
when the crown was ready the King
suspected that the goldsmith cheated and
slipped some silver into the crown
keeping some of the gold for himself the
King asked Archimedes to solve the
problem but there was a catch he
couldn't do any damage to the crown one
day while taking his bath
Archimedes noticed that the water level
in the bathtub rose and overflowed as he
immersed himself into the tub he
suddenly realized that how much water
was displaced depended on how much of
his body was immersed this discovery
excited him so much they jumped out of
the tub and ran through the streets
naked shouting Eureka which comes from
the ancient Greek meaning I found it
what did he find
well he found a way to solve the Kings
problem you see Archimedes needed to
check the Crown's density to see if it
was the same as the density of pure gold
density is a measure of an object's mass
divided by its volume pure gold is very
dense while silver is less dense so if
there was silver in the crown it would
be less dense than if it were made of
pure gold but no matter what it was made
of the crown would be the same shape
which means the same volume so if
Archimedes could measure the mass of the
crown first and then measure its volume
he could find out how dense it was but
it is not easy to measure Crown's volume
it has an irregular shape that's
different from a simple box or ball you
can't measure its size and multiply like
you might for other shapes the solution
Archimedes realized was to give the
crown a bath by placing it in water and
seeing how much water was displaced he
could measure the volume they need to
calculate the density of the crown if
the crown was less dense than pure gold
then the goldsmith most definitely
cheated the king when Archimedes went
back to the king and did his test the
story says he found that the Goldsmith
had indeed cheated the King and slipped
some silver in these days using the way
an object displaces water to measure
volume is called Archimedes principle
the next time you take a bath you can
see Archimedes principle in action and
maybe you'll have a genius idea of your
own